as king charles iii takes his place on
the throne royal titles are shifting in
terms of the matter of titles yes we can
expect some changes and we're learning
prince harry and meghan markle's two
kids archie and lillabet can now be
called prince and princess
as the son of a monarch harry's children
will be entitled to take a royal title
the duke and duchess of sussex remain
with their current titles and as of now
their little ones are the first ever
prince and princess of sussex but the
question is for how long and will the
sussexes let them keep those titles to
understand we gotta go back in time all
the way to 1917 when a law was put in
place that kids of a king prince william
and prince harry and their kids george
charlotte louis archie and lillabet have
the right to hold his or her royal
highness titles plus they also get to
add prince or princess to their names
william and kate middleton's kids
already have the titles and now megan
and harry's kids can do the same
we're just so thrilled to have have our
own little bundle of joy
megan previously addressed archie's lack
of a prince title in her bombshell
sit-down interview with oprah last year
but now that things have changed
ironically there's a chance they may not
hold on to those titles for long there's
speculation that as charles takes on his
role as king he might limit the number
of key royals if he chooses to amend the
1917 law it would prevent archie and
lillabet from having royal titles only
time will tell if charles chooses to
revoke those rights but as of now archie
is sixth in line to the throne behind
prince william his three kids and prince
harry the house of windsor is secure
that the succession is secure
but what about title changes for the
rest of the royal family well in the
wake of queen elizabeth's death her
eldest son charles formerly the prince
of wales was automatically named king
what we do know about the titles is that
king charles has decided to be king
charles iii and we do know camilla
became queen consort
prince william and kate middleton
formerly known as the duke and duchess
of cambridge are now known as the prince
and princess of wales titles previously
held by william's father and mother
princess diana there have been
inevitable comparisons between katherine
and the princess of wales ever since she
got engaged to prince william i think
one of the duchess of cambridge's
greatest
successes has been
creating a new role from herself away
from the shadows of princess diana but
of course she was always going to
inherit the title the princess of wales
and she more than anyone will know that
they are sizable shoes to fill
[Music]